nick trop vite les gens et des canettes
pg c'est amusant non mais c'est marrant
si cet égard en prend la voiture assez
marrant prend la pole a
fait tester un nouveau produit c'est
payant n'a pas beaucoup c'est un premier
énergétique c'est à nouveau sur les
gouttes gouttes
commencé à base de gingembre
ginseng caféine acide ascorbique non
mais beaucoup de succès pour enlever le
goût du sang de porc
et le dut dérivés de pétrole c'est une
nouvelle boisson énergétique suicide à
goûtez moi ça à l'aller à l'est pas pas
de ça avec moi
on sent on sent un peu le le désir monte
en soi
et au packaging vous préférez plutôt au
toucher ou qu'elle est comme ça ou
plutôt oui
je vous aime quoi une joute
assez énergétique c'est pour ça alors à
la prise en main
ja oui
non non non
qu'est-ce qui se passe
séoul a
annoncé
jeudi un premier coup du fait que vous
êtes vachement réceptive aux
jeans scène ah ben je sais pas je peux
pas vous dire mais je vous assure que
j'ai fait un coup de fil un nom mais je
voudrais dans le rôle de nerfs
ainsi si vous êtes au médium
c'est ça mais moi je suis x l'arche moi
vous n'êtes pas diabétique n'avait pas
de problèmes gastriques ah merde merde
merde buvait pas ça malheureux ça fait
des trous ça c'est vous vous sentez
monter le désir envie
d'un bon mot on y va tout de suite
ça fait laxatifs aussi à quoi ça sert à
tout oui c'est bien
[Musique]